Je pense que j'ai vu beaucoup de gens à bon escient à quel point
c'était grave de pleurer derrière moi
absolument magnifique
tout le monde sanglotait me donne presque
envie de pleurer maintenant je pense que c'est juste
parce que c'était une histoire vraie qui m'a
coupé le cœur examiné ça l'a repoussé
et  dit que nous allons bien maintenant, mais le
troisième truc où tu viens de Calcutta
kiss bud je suis adopté je ne suis pas vraiment
indien tu commences à te souvenir
nous sommes très fiers de toi fils eh bien je me bats
oublié j'en avais un autre  famille une mère
davender son frère reconnaissant envers moi
chérie je peux encore voir leurs visages
De Luca soit Zama
non on sait bon
je dois retrouver le chemin du retour
[Musique]
ils prendraient une vie entière pour chercher toutes
les stations en Inde
[Musique]
ou si tu découvres
c'est de l'eau tu ne peux pas avoir tes propres
enfants Je vais le faire nous avons choisi de ne pas nous
choisir ensemble
[Musique]
pas la même chose nous recevons
Carrie
tous les soirs j'imagine que je  Je marche dans
ces rues pour rentrer chez
moi et je murmure dépêche-toi je suis là
toi